hello i'm chris hemsworth i'm going to
be taking the buzzfeed trivia quiz
[Music]
which of these stanley cameos happens in
thor so we have the barber we have a
fedex delivery man world war ii veteran
and the truck driver
and uh it's i'd say it's the barber
which it is because i recognize
the costume and that outfit it's very uh
ragnarok
all right question number two
uh oh wait a second wait a second it's
wrong
are you kidding i'm wrong
that says here i'm wrong okay i don't
believe these questions but uh a truck
driver stan appears as a truck driver
who uses his car to try and lift me on
him from the crater
he does but doesn't he also appear in
that first one
is this got two is there two answers is
that the thing
oh see i was just thinking thor is in
for any thought all right no no okay in
the avengers what piece of memorabilia
does agent coulson want captain america
to sign captain america trading cards a
replica of cap's shield an original
shield handbook from the 1940s a captain
america poster
oh no idea
um
i'd say
cap shield
wrong okay natasha tells steve how proud
of their trading cards coulson is then
later when colson dies fury uses the
card as a way to motivate steve and to
fight tony okay all right all right i'm
terrible at this game in thor ragnarok
how long does loki say he's been falling
before doctor strange returns him to
thor
15 minutes 30 minutes 45 minutes or two
hours i remember him saying i've been
falling for
30 minutes let's try 30
[Music]
correct
minutes
you go
next question in avengers infinity war
who is the last person we see get dusted
on screen by thanos's snap
is it nick fury is it uh
wanda is it peter parker is it groot hmm
i'm gonna say peter parker
wrong
nick fury in the post-credits scene the
last person we see get dusted is next
fury he disappears right after he calls
captain marvel okay
next question in spider-man far from
home what gift does peter sneak off and
buy for mj a leaning tower of a piece of
keychain
uh
a first edition copy of pride and
prejudice a black dollar necklace a dual
headphone adapter
hmm
no idea guys
headphone adapter
wrong okay
a black darling necklace peter buys and
lady gives mj a black dahlia necklace
next one and finally in one division
what is the first line in the song
agatha all along
it's either who's been pulling every
evil string who controlled this whole
thing
who's been messing up everything
it's been agatha all along yeah i have
no idea
i'm just gonna do that and i miss the
screen i'm gonna do that
it's just the whole thing's broken
they're not wrong
okay
one out of six
okay
well i scored better than 67 percent of
all the quiz taggers
i mean you're a marvel cinematic
universe newcomer
you're pretty new to the mcu but you're
having a blast catching up on all the
movies
sure am
i just want to say that i have the
jury's out and whether i was
you know the first question i know it
said it happens in thor but that could
have been for
one two three four i'm gonna give it to
me and i'm gonna say
it's two out of six
i'm chris hemsworth and i got one out of
six questions right in the uh
the trivia quiz there and uh i believe
that the game is rigged somehow because
i should have done better than that but
i didn't sorry and go check out thor
love and thunder
it is a wild wacky ride romantic comedy
mixed in with a hell of a lot of
cinematic marvel epic action
[Music]
you